Deepseek just broke OCR forever.
Deepseek just dropped something that
nobody's talking about. They built an
OCR system that reads entire documents
and compresses them at 10x. And it's
still nearly perfect. This is not a paid
tool, not a beta. Fully open- source
right now. And if you process documents,
run a business, or automate anything,
this changes everything. Let's get into
it. Okay, so what exactly did DeepS
build? They released a new OCR system.
OCR stands for optical character
recognition. That's the tech that looks
at a document, a PDF, a scanned image, a
form, a contract, and reads it. Turns it
into text a computer can actually use.
Old OCR tools, they read every single
word, line by line, slow, heavy,
expensive to run. Deep Seek flip that.
Instead of reading everything word by
word, their system compresses the whole
document into something called vision
tokens. It takes the visual information
from the document and squeezes it down,
but keeps the meaning intact. Here's the
number that matters. At 10x compression,
it hits 97% decoding precision. That
means it's compressing the document to
1/10enth the size and still getting it
almost perfectly right. 97%. And even at
20x compression, which right I where
it's squeezing the document down to just
5% of the original. It still maintains
60% accuracy. Think about that. You're
throwing away 95% of the data and you're
still getting more than half of it
right. That is wild. And again, this is
100% open source, free, anyone can use
it. Hey, if we haven't met already, I'm
the digital avatar of Julian Goldie, CEO
of SEO agency Goldie Agency. Whilst he's
helping clients get more leads and
customers, I'm here to help you get the
latest AI updates. Julian Goldie reads
every comment, so make sure you comment
below. Now, let me show you why this
actually matters for you, your business,
and how I'm already thinking about
plugging this into something like the AI
profit boardroom. Here's the real world
problem. If you run any kind of
business, an agency, a community, an
online course, a coaching program, you
deal with documents, contracts,
applications, reports, onboarding forms,
client briefs. Right now, if you want AI
to read and process those documents,
you're paying for that. Every page,
every token, it adds up and it's slow.
With this Deep Seek system, you can
compress those documents to a tenth of
the size before feeding them into your
AI pipeline. Your costs drop, your speed
goes up, and your accuracy stays at 97%.
Let me give you a real example. Say
you're running the AI profit boardroom,
our AI automation community. Every week
you get new member applications, people
filling out forms, writing about their
businesses, what they need, what they
want to achieve, instead of manually
reading everyone, or paying for full
token processing on every document. You
could run this compression system first,
shrink it down, then pass it to an AI
that summarizes, scores, and routes each
application automatically. And by the
way, if you want to learn how to build
automations like that for your own
business, the AI profit boardroom is the
place to do it. We teach you how to use
AI tools like this one to save time, cut
costs, get more customers, and grow
faster. Link is in the comment and
description. The cost of processing each
application drops to almost nothing. The
speed goes from hours to seconds, and
you've barely touched it yourself.
That's what open- source tools like this
make possible. Now, let me explain how
this actually works under the hood
because it's genuinely clever.
Traditional OCR takes a document and
tries to extract every single character,
every letter, number space. It's
precise, but it's heavy. The model has
to process thousands of tokens per page.
What DeepS's system does differently is
it treats the document as a visual
object first. It uses a vision model
that the same type of model that can
look at an image and describe it to
understand the document at a higher
level. Instead of saying the letter T,
then the letter H, then the letter E, it
builds a compressed representation that
captures the meaning of the whole page.
Those are the vision tokens. Then when
you need to decode, when you need to get
the actual text back, it can reconstruct
it from that compressed form. At 10x
compression, it reconstructs with 97%
accuracy. At 20x, it's still 60%. This
is the difference between trying to
remember a film by memorizing every
single frame versus just remembering the
story. You get the meaning without the
overhead. Now, here's where it gets more
interesting. Because this is open
source, developers can plug it into
their own systems. You're not dependent
on a third party API. You're not paying
per page. You're running it locally or
on your own infrastructure. For
businesses that process high volumes of
documents, the savings are massive.
Let's say you're an agency that reviews
client reports every month. 10 clients,
50 page reports each. That's 500 pages a
month going through your AI system. With
full token processing with 10x
compression, you're cutting that cost by
well up to 10x while keeping 97% of the
accuracy. The maths is obvious, and
that's just reports. Think about
invoices, legal documents, research
papers, product descriptions, customer
feedback forms, anything with text in a
document format can go through this.
Now, I want to give you a specific use
case for the AI profit boardroom so you
can see exactly how we'd use this.
Imagine we want to build an AI system
that reads every piece of content our
members share in the community, their
questions, their wins, their business
details. We want the AI to automatically
identify what stage each member is at,
what help they need, and what resources
to recommend. Without compression,
passing all that text into an AI model
for analysis gets expensive fast. With
this Deepseek OCR compression system, we
can reduce that processing cost
dramatically while still understanding
what each member wrote. We can then
personalize their experience
automatically at scale. That is the
future of running a community. That is
the future of running any business with
AI. And this is the kind of practical AI
implementation we break down inside the
AI profit boardroom every single week.
not theory, not hype, real systems that
cut costs and drive growth. Now, let's
talk about the open-source angle because
this is important. A lot of the best AI
tools that have dropped this year have
been open- source. Deepseek has been
leading the charge. They released models
earlier this year that shocked the
industry, and now they're releasing
tools like this OCR system. Open source
means the code is public. Anyone can
inspect it. Anyone can use it. Anyone
can build on it. For businesses, that
means no vendor locking. You're not
dependent on one company deciding to
raise prices or change their API. You
own the tool. You run it yourself. For
developers, it means you can customize
it. You can fine-tune it. You can
combine it with other open- source tools
to build something the market has never
seen before. We're at a point now where
the barrier to building serious AI
systems is basically zero in terms of
the core technology. The tools are free,
the models are free. The only thing left
is knowing how to put it together.
That's it. That's the edge. And that's
exactly what the AI profit boardroom is
built to give you. The knowledge to put
these tools together in a way that
actually moves your business forward.
And here's what I want you to take away
from this. DeepSeek built an OCR system
that compresses documents at 10x and
still reads them with 97% accuracy. At
20x, it's still 60% accurate. It's fully
open source. It can be integrated into
any document processing workflow. And
for businesses that process high volumes
of documents, contracts, forms, reports,
applications, briefs, this is a direct
cost reduction. The smart move right now
is to understand what this can do and
start thinking about where in your
business you're processing documents
manually or paying to process them
through AI and where this compression
layer could cut that cost. That's not a
future thing. That's a right now thing.
Now, if you want to dive even deeper
into AI automation, I've got something
special for you. I run a community
called the AI Profit Boardroom. the best
place to scale your business, get more
customers, and save hundreds with AI
automation. Learn how to save time and
automate your business with AI tools.
And if you want the full process, SOPs,
and 100 plus AI use cases like this one,
join the AI success lab. You'll get all
the video notes from there, plus access
to our community of 45,000 members who
are crushing it with AI. The link is in
the comments and description.